war in ukraine a chinese tech crackdown
and slipping stock prices pushed 329
people off forbes 2022 list of the
world's billionaires including 169
one-hit wonders who were part of last
year's record 493 newcomers it's the
largest number of drop-offs since 2009
when the financial crisis knocked 355
people off the list three countries
accounted for two-thirds of the
drop-offs china russia and the us china
had 153 drop-offs including four from
hong kong in fact of the 10 former
billionaires whose net worth sank the
most eight were from china the fortunes
of this year's two biggest losers jean
bangshin of tal education and larry
jiangdong chen of rival gsx tech edu
evaporated when the chinese government
took steps to ban profits and overseas
investment in the after-school tutoring
industry russia lost 35 billionaires
including oleg tinkov whose digital bank
tinkoff shed 90 of its share value in
london after russia invaded ukraine
before trading was suspended on march
2nd in late april tinkov announced he
would sell his remaining 35 stake in the
bank to billionaire oligarch vladimir
putin under pressure from the kremlin
after tinkov spoke out against the war
33 u.s billionaires fell off the list
including rj scarange founder and ceo of
startup electric vehicle maker rivian
less than a year ago rivien had raised a
record 23.1 billion dollars including
11.9 billion dollars in its november ipo
which valued the company at 90 billion
dollars but scarange has struggled to
ramp up production ever since
disappointing analysts and sending
shares spiraling 64 by forbes's march
11th measurement date for the list
former tech billionaires whose fortunes
soared more than any other group during
the pandemic were hit the hardest 53
dropped off including 32 from china and
hong kong
fashion and retail lost 45 billionaires
manufacturing lost 33 and real estate
lost 29. two of covet 19's biggest early
winners the healthcare and finance
sectors also lost 25 billionaires apiece